la incertidumbre colma la escena en la
frontera entre México y Estados Unidos
la decisión de la Corte Suprema de
prorrogar el título 42 la orden de
emergencia de Lara Trump que permite
expulsar a los migrantes por razones
sanitarias preocupa a las personas que
pretendían cruzar el paso fronterizo
hacia Estados Unidos
y la verdad Nos cae como como
un bar de Dando y ahora nos dicen de que
no de que lo alargaron más el artículo
42 y ya no sabemos qué hacer sin embargo
esta extensión pedida por los estados
controlados por republicanos y que
durará al menos hasta finales de junio
no derrumba las esperanzas de los
migrantes yo salí de mi país con la
intención de cruzar de llegar los
Estados Unidos y yo todavía no me daba
por vencido yo voy a seguir mi rumbo así
sea quedarme aquí en México
o
para aquel lado pero mi sueño es cruza
para aquel lado tengo temor de cruzar
así ilegal porque me da temor que me que
me agarren me atrapen y me devuelvan y
aparecen en el sistema ya no pueda
ingresar a Estados Unidos Entonces
quiero esperar mejor porque yo tengo la
fe y la esperanza que sí van a dar una
noticia y bueno y esperaré la medida de
la Corte Suprema que cuenta con marcada
mayoría conservadora fue criticada el
martes por el presidente Joe biden quien
la calificó como pero reconoció que
deberán hacerla cumplir mientras que la
suerte de miles de migrantes queda la
deriva en territorio mexicano